hey I was goin brosman is I'm so excited
to keep playing this awesome game for
you bros good thing what a perfect way
to end it previously on until dawn hold
on there is one individual we're
considering as a person of interest he
has an interesting history with the
Washington family apparently he had
warned them against pursuing their
construction project in Blackwood Pines
and claimed the land was sacred to his
forefathers a warning is hardly a threat
ask your sister Josh it's gotta be it's
just he's the bad guy I know it I feel
it no other one has a motive come on my
god the clown great fantastic [ __ ]
clown oh my god this [ __ ] looks
like a spider when she comes out so here
we go let's keep playing loyalty 7 hours
until dawn
dress
we're gonna quick scope no scope of that
[ __ ] let's risk a shortcut
alright I'm ready for the QuickTime
events so you ready broke Oh triangle
that [ __ ] Circle that [ __ ] oh
my god what happens if we fall in that's
what I love about these games you get
one chance and if you [ __ ] up that's
gonna change the story really keeps the
own edge
we're gonna quickscope there it is up
that it there's that ass dress where she
crawling from imma come on why don't I
check my god
why don't I'm just shoot at the guy
instead of her let's jump down we got
this bro
[ __ ] never mind [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
wow man I'm buck like a man the [ __ ]
guy from uncharted I knew it that's it
it took me so long to figure out who
where I had to recognize him
triangle that tree yeah oh god I [ __ ]
up
wow that hurts that really hurts
I clicked circle instead of triangle
there's the circle thank you
sorry I get weird twitches sometimes all
right we better not [ __ ] up the jump are
we jumping we jump ring no Radek
come on baby check off yeah triangle why
do I suck so much dang I'm so sorry
thanks thanks for telling me wrong room
we made it anyway so that kind of takes
away the spell
risk slide down
oh my gasps oh we did it Mikey boy come
on Mikey boy oh that's pretty badass yes
we will take this up awesome
do you even know how to shoot that thing
Mike so I think we can save her i legit
think she doesn't have to die so let's
try and make the right move here right
cuz we meet to party get that booty
elevator yeah that seems
I am really taking my time here our
night unsafe keep app got it oh she's
down here why am I not running I don't
it sounds like it comes from here No
okay we're we're here now she dead oh
she's yes yes yes yes we can still get
laid that's horrible
I'm so sorry
she then she dead
I'm a quickscope that [ __ ] all right
here we go time to shoot where's my I
was like where's my [ __ ] crosshair
hey guys no thought more cute
I don't want to [ __ ] this up come on
Mike your man you can do this quick one
this is not [ __ ] up names
nice nice nice
yeah what's up no big deal we got this
Wow there yes come on what if you didn't
say it quick scope that [ __ ]
come on bro you [ __ ] up now I just
gotta make it
right you need to stop talking to
yourself right fresh fresh
amnesia style this is really intense I
really like this
his nipples must be so hard from Nicole
I like how he doesn't even care about
Jessica anymore he's just like yeah well
want to get the guy
[ __ ] is that flight
that [ __ ] is that place a new place
that's where he was going wasn't it oh
yeah they got knocked out by the clown
and the clown is obviously dodge and
actually got taken away cool we can do
this we'll save her and we'll have many
cat ladies together I mean cats ash ash
where did it go
that's oh no that's favorite ash
favorite soap
okay
man what a shitty [ __ ] party man it
reminds me a little bit of scooby-doo I
don't know why this is like a masked
killer and I'm a little [ __ ] said it I
don't know you tell me
cool what are we looking exactly Oh my
load
they love jump scares in this game just
as much as I love buttcheeks [ __ ] that
might be finger painting don't worry
it's in mine it might not be that bad
ash you out here girl you won't catch
some Pokemon we'll catch them Pikachu's
bat a bat bat bat bat better better
about that the difference father do you
father do you
where are they actually I don't think to
care that much I wish there was a button
to yell Ashley like in heavy rain that's
like the best feature ever actually
Ashley Ashley the Burke's are going here
so I guess I'll go here Oh Ashley more
like deadly oh [ __ ] me
Oh button that's how this may pounce me
you shall not pass [ __ ] ah oh
[ __ ] that's not Ashley that's a pig
she's gonna be pissed if I thought I
didn't a clue found so these are all the
clues to the mystery I mean it can't be
that easy that it's just [ __ ] Josh if
that's how they lay it out it's like at
this tonin
deaf totem oh god no
who was that was that us could we
potentially die here why is our dead end
here I mean something's gotta get
triggered when we exit here that is so
creepy
maybe not maybe I was [ __ ] wrong Jesus
Christ all along they that wear a
[ __ ] piling just to sing this [ __ ]
sound where the hell is Grace this girl
Ashley - I have a feeling she's not
gonna answer you Jesus Christ
shut up he's like oh that's my name
don't wear it out
oh my god what cabin is this is this our
cabin
okay here we go doors open oh [ __ ] we
hear her Ashley you caught some Pokemon
Ashley Ashley I'm gonna get you out of
this don't worry don't worry about it
Chris are you there
yes I'm here and thank you all for
joining me [ __ ] is this song night what
we're gonna do that little experiment
now this is sawdust now for this
experiment we'll need the cooperation of
our two test subjects Joshua and Ashley
but we're gonna need one more brave
participant to help decide which subject
will live and which will die please
please please everyone calm down it's
all very simple
Christopher you will find a lever placed
directly in front of you all you have to
do is choose who you will say
okay okay okay it's gonna be okay it's
gonna be okay well that's pretty easy
I'm gonna save Ashley I'm gonna get laid
sorry
now we're friends man
you know I know he's fine he's just in
two pieces now okay I'll take the back
maybe Josh you seem to kill it my God my
god
I mean it could be a fake torso and he
could just be as head through the wall
I'm not giving up on the Josh theory yet
Josh it might still be this is insane we
need to go
Matt we need to go get help now Thank
You Jess are often sixty-nining each
other and who knows where salmon the
cheese in the lodge fine fine you're
right get everyone else together but if
there's a maniac running around I think
we need to get to health too right stick
together around don't split up they
always split up Ashley what's your
attitude [ __ ] maybe I should kill your
next [ __ ]
more like ash Lowell I'm all right no
they split up good job you did it you
won you want it harm hey Pitt that Oh
nice Peter oh good friend you got there
it's going fine all right hey hey hey
what's your attitude you you're supposed
to be like you mine I know what you want
this time you play you understand that
it's not good for you it's not good but
why did you make it then I can't say
very charitable the way you play bro I'm
trying here people die all right so my
fault
to continue with this elaborate don't
you yes oh you're Peter Stormare I know
you're real comes down to this
interesting previously and until dawn I
feel like we just saw one I mean all
right well let's look again let's all be
reminded of sleet falling out the window
oh yeah we're gonna play as her now I
like her
nice quit it here's our one-way ticket
to the spirit realm I've just been
through enough spooking for one night
okay I see a hot bath and my crystal
ball don't have fun you guys agree with
my decision oh my god there is one
individual we're considering as a person
of interest but his whereabouts are
currently unknown you know there is
still the old sanatorium on the mountain
could he be hiding there oh the old
sanatorium oh [ __ ]
thinks about to get Missy Bruce oh [ __ ]
okay
it's no good yeah
if I can wolf
he has wolves following him and I got
nothing but bare skin what was that
was that
this is not the clown I wouldn't use the
Latin it's an easy way to get spotted
are those the wolves this is creepy I
don't like this
Brice look at the who would enter a
[ __ ] sanatorium with a killer why are
we looking for Ashley although she fell
down his [ __ ] but at least check no just
me alright so he walked here didn't he
I want to see what he was looking
all right so what is this secret
entrance perhaps
there you go buddy
no problem no problem at all have
fabrice yes should probably close the
door though because now he knows we're
inside well never mind that never mind
any life form of thinking instead of
just rushing into things
Jesus Christ we're gonna die in here I'm
rig impressed by doing with the [ __ ]
arm
that's something up there
how do we get night
let's get back
maybe there's a way to get up
Klieman ease
No
maybe there's this ladder
what that [ __ ] is he doing for that arm
everybody dance up or down move it all
around do the lantern something
clearly missing something
I mean yes I see that it's there but I
can't reach it it's a broken ladder here
isn't it maybe like we can go back in
time to when the ladder wasn't broken
like in life is strange that'd be cool I
just walk into circles net up and see
this good job me [ __ ] angles how do
they work barrel
I will move you move you Berra Babbitt
ffffff bad up a bit about that Mahmood
barrel did it 10 points to Gryffindor 10
points the Uncharted man
okay doing good this is a puzzle hasn't
been any puzzles so far and stress
interestingly enough I guess that just
takes away the pacing from the movie
like feeling I really do enjoy the
pacing so far what am I looking I'm
going full amnesia style okay
we saw something here what is that Oh a
way to get out fair enough
use your parkour skills why is there a
[ __ ] hole in the ground
no that's creepier that's the right
[ __ ] answer Jesus Christ oh my god
why am i following this [ __ ] why am I
not getting help I'm clearly way over my
head
really Wow Pro proper
security pass require fair enough
I'm sure those are easy to get by maybe
there's a dead body here somewhere you
know I'm saying you know I'm
crack-a-lackin' yo maybe we can get up
somewhere of a half cost no big deal no
big deal at all
let's go in the ad that makes sense
actually let's check this out because
it's glowing and anything shiny is like
I am looking at it thank you nice that's
not creepy at all
it's a pretty cool place gotta say I'm
impressed now shouldn't we go to the
more I don't know let's just keep
exploring see what we can find
reporter Pines
a reporter was assaulted and
hospitalized the man had been trapped
underground for three weeks
what was that sound it is believed that
the assault arose from an argument about
Bernstein's camera which was come escape
interesting very interesting flu okay
let's keep looking
let's check in here is that where we
came from let's go to the morgue then
this is really creepy oh my God he's
[ __ ] noises and [ __ ] another clue
perhaps yes one of those guys actually
tried to bite me
okay good tacks
I wish anyone would bite me am i right
ladies
up top okay what it's in here
Oh going down to the morgue
that's creepy creepy creepy creepy
creepy creepy creepy hello
send one down here and the dead people
want to dance
bro a crow brat another clue perhaps but
is this hello
[ __ ] crows we should take that dude
that's [ __ ] disgusting
that's right we go fine for a laugh to
party of course he has a machete holder
in his jeans every man has a machete
holder in their [ __ ] jeans
you're not a man unless you have a
machete holder just in case there's
someone murdering your girlfriend and
you happen to find a machete I'm just
keepin it real yo keeping it real home
dogs
and okay I just have to check everything
you know I'm saying you're filling me
okay time to stamps whoa that's creepy
any scream for Liz look at this thing
oh I can't go here you [ __ ] [ __ ]
angles man hello hello hello
but it's clue in there can I go in Jake
you know that's creepy
oh nice what the [ __ ] is this I might
find gas it was a trap No
no no oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh oh oh how convenient
Jesus Christ
oh good taps key taps forehead glad we
did that
well at least we neither eyes look at
her fingers they're just they're
taunting us oops something here shiny
this place just gets better and better
strange skull Pulu found interesting
what about over here well we knew all
that already know
are you sure is out I'll find a [ __ ]
pink car don't worry bro we got this
we're gonna finally
hello hello hello
you got a key card on your brow this is
normal
this is normalizing oh dude
Oh a key card yeah lucky cards okay all
right okay there's many different ones
let's see if this one works first
oh cool how do you lock it then doesn't
matter I guess
okay spooky spooky spooky I really want
him to live that's why I'm like so
concentrated just lost two fingers we
seem to be doing fine and a girlfriend
we lost our girlfriend - we got our only
chance
there's a nice puppy nice puppy
run run run run run run run run come on
we're faster
try puppy learn to use doors [ __ ]
nailed it what is this [ __ ] place
there he is
it's going in the elevator what is going
on in here there's a quaint little
psycho grandma quaint little psycho
fence perfect way to say it I still
don't agree with this decision I'm going
in after a murderer alone but hey it
reminds me of when when Luke and Darth
waiter fights in that one window you
remember that's so weird
alright let's go to the channel I love
me some Chaplin
good thing we brought the machete
yeah but we still don't have the key
card or do we they would bring it yeah
we do oh [ __ ]
thank God we do okay whoo no problem no
problem yeah
did it proud of your breasts this is
amazing oh can it go in punch you in the
dick sorry I'm sorry dawg
I'm sorry I don't like I bet myself I
bet my [ __ ] leg can just kick a dog
don't look at Gary don't look shiny
what's inside oh we can use these a bone
who doesn't like a good old bone to chew
on if you know what I mean I'm top
ladies every go god damn it hey maybe we
can make that a dog chew through that
the log oh that's here let's check this
out
another clue huh what's this one about
the clipping war the work of an
obsessive man
well someone that walks around with
[ __ ] bolts in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere and beds and usually not like
the good signs am i right
what do we got over here jacket is it
product he was trying to cover up
we can go through right don't trust this
oh nice Allah Allah Allah
check for bullets check for [ __ ]
bullets right now I can't great good job
you did it well you win that nothing
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright we can shoot open the door
probably I think that's the point
pretty sure this guy's is luring us here
anyway
I don't really doing good I can't lie
doing pretty [ __ ] good man I like it
I like it I like it
let's go down this is cool you really
appreciate the level design feels like a
real place when you just look at it just
me alright it's fair enough
and wonder what studio made this
era of course locked what's behind the
barrel get the [ __ ] out of my way barrel
Bhim
you did it you did it dude wipsy is at
the end it was all right press we're
gonna have to end that episode there
this is getting really exciting I'll see
you tomorrow with the new episode thank
you both so much for watching and
leaving a like I really appreciate it as
always stay awesome